hot breath so what can comics do now to
like you said comedy is changing i think
comedy change i mean
you know i i i don't know i think
i mean look what's the last special you
saw that was like wow
shouldn't even take you that long right
true did
when you asked us you know prior live in
concert
eddie murphy raw eddie murphy delirious
george carl
i mean you know what i'm saying mm-hmm
now there's so much out there
that's what was going through my head
you saw so many things that you don't
know
what the to pick
you're nervous to tell me like is this a
good one
exactly you don't know but nobody knows
the greats
i mean yeah chappelle right burr i guess
and
you know maybe ellen you know there's so
much stuff out there right now it's hard
to you know but i think somebody's gonna
do it somebody's gonna pop out
somebody's gonna have something where
we're gonna go what the is that
usually in comedy when it gets saturated
somebody just takes a left
and does something different you know
what do you think that would be
like i don't know vr stand up or ar
somebody's gonna just say
you and talk about up
and
you're gonna have to deal with it and
not care you know eddie murphy and
delirious came out and
said and got from everybody
you know and then they just went up and
raw and talked about it
now there's a real gag on top of the
congo
i mean you yeah you know what i
mean i mean
it's just you know i think something
like that will happen you know
um i know maybe not maybe this is just
what it is now
maybe comedy is just little pockets of
these people like this and those people
like that and the masses
you know like this and
i have no clue dude
you